so welcome to council geeks my name's
Nathaniel Wayne and I am joined again by
Ryan Daley polsce veto Jason sharer and
we're still talking avengers age of
ultron only this time we're talking
spoilers so if you haven't seen the
movie please go away unless you don't
care in which case stick around let's
actually start talking vision it felt a
little like what I would expect to
justice league movie when Superman shows
up it's like this is the guy who's gonna
fix everything and he looked fine and
actually I was impressed like it was
practical I major props for going proud
I was certain he was he was going to be
a motion capture but like that's a no
that's Paul Bettany and makeup and yeah
cool first of all I know this is the
spoiler one but I'm still not even going
to say it just in case um there is the
visual gag related to the vision in this
film that floored me mm-hmm at the same
time as soon as it happened part of me
kind of recoiled and said really
overpowered how are they gonna handle
this he's got an infinity stone is fine
how much you want to bet that that that
becomes the oh [ __ ] we're all in trouble
moment in infinity wars when Thanos gets
it out of the vision I think she's
graduated to a rag doll no I think he's
gonna wear the vision on his fish huge
thing that was missing for me scenes
that were obviously deleted was Thor
coming to the decision that yeah vision
had to exist yeah you know cuz like he
goes into the pool to go back into his
jury animal my collision next time you
see him he interrupts everything by
bringing the vision to life with
electricity Joss Whedon said Thor had a
lot more that was cut up it's almost
like dark world had no impact this
domain is man 3 had no impact on the
beginning of this movie yeah I know it
wiped out the ending of iron man 3 oh by
the way I have the iron force no wait
didn't you joy
or hu of your I mean there are some
things coming into this that I'm Duke
bugged me on that level but at the same
time you look at the comic books and
they do that [ __ ] all the damn yeah I
and the thing is the fans are gonna
forgive iron man having the Iron Man
suits and they're just on the thing that
that was beating me over the head the
entire time during this movie was the
post 9-11 metaphor it's going to have
shots at street level yeah of smoke
rolling across yes yeah cars man it's
like this looks like September 11th and
then you have the captain america vs
tony stark argument you know Tony Stark
saying is the paramilitary i'm going to
do what's necessary to destroy the
threat whereas captain america is the
transparent military fighting for all
that's good in the world you know and
that's the post 9-11 argument right yeah
there's one thing that i want to point
out because i don't know where else in
the discussion to point this out sure
but it was something that I loved and
especially if I if I want to pick on DC
I know what you're talking I know where
you're going I love that it was a
priority that they gives he gets
civilians to safety yes not just an act
3 even when right when the whole Buster
fight is going on when he finds a
building to slam the hook into he does a
scan of the building like this is a half
constructed building there was no one in
it and only then does he throw the whole
definitely in contrast to the insane
collateral damage that was on display in
Man of Steel with no regret and as the
resident animation nut that has also
been a problem with the new animated DC
films as well there is no regard for
collateral damage I was just oh they
they're heroes they save people that's
right they're not just there to kill the
bad guy they save the people see Matthew
that was one of the aspects that I love
that the conscious effort that they may
just save everybody because that brings
me to something else okay as soon as
Nick Fury showed up I was like shouldn't
be here but he was there because it's an
Avengers movie and he kind of has to be
and the story did not need him yeah it
could have been obese mothers character
who what
um brought the Helicarrier brother Kerry
what were people's feelings on on Pietro
and Wanda because we can't call them the
other things cuz Fox owns that yeah and
screw Fox i'll just call him Quicksilver
okay well we'll start with him for my
part I considering that I was expecting
to be let down given how awesome he was
in Days of Future past I amen I liked
him much more than I thought I was going
to I was convinced there is no way that
this is even going to be entertaining
based off what I saw on that film yeah
in what he did he did still work I liked
his attitude he had that bit of
cockiness yeah that that I liked and
since since we are talking to spoilers I
am glad that they finally killed
somebody and let him stay dead cuz I've
been calling for that for about three
movies now that somebody aside from a
villain needed to die and stay dead I
felt like their motivations were overly
simplistic mmm for what they were doing
is like oh there was a bomb in the room
for two days it says stark on it did we
actually get the sort of moment of
catharsis for them where they reconciled
their moment with Tony no no they never
reconciled with no they never really
have a moment with him at all that I can
think of that I mean they obviously
don't and join The Avengers went upon
realizing what Ultron is actually trying
to do that's the thing if their whole
motivation and going back to start our
is to stop him yeah the birth of vision
really kind of throws everybody's
personal agenda out the window yeah and
everybody just has to say everything
that we've been building two for two
hours to okay just put that on hold we
have to save the world go okay get him
back to to Quicksilver Petrov I couldn't
conceive of them giving him a scene that
would be better than what he had in
x-men days of future past oh yeah he
wasn't a character he was just that
scene yeah yeah it was just is like okay
it's such a good scenes a really good
sense like but comparing the characters
he was a character in this movie and he
might not have stopped the show like he
did in x-men days of future past but I
cared about him a lot more and this
to the point where I was like yeah you
had to kill somebody but I was just
really starting to like your dinner our
speedster fan has not really weighed in
and I you're right I do love me some
speedsters um I thought he was fun to
watch they slowed him down I would argue
in this movie and so he would he was
easier to hit I would say that this was
a less power or nerfed if you'll excuse
the term-- version of of Quicksilver in
this film and so understandable you how
many go but the problem was that's why
they got rid of a nine days we pass also
I loved the look at it didn't look like
x-men and it didn't look like a flash it
was a unique version a unique look for a
speedster yep um I always liked watching
him do his stuff I listen I disagreed
that he didn't he again you never bored
me really there were times when I didn't
understand but forward me so then then
that brings us to Wanda scarlet witch
yep so I got well I give props elizabeth
Olsen as an actress in this one because
how hard has it got to be I mean number
one the characters powers basically seem
to be whatever just needed at the time
but you know how hard has it got to be
for an actor or an actress to do this
all day you know I and keep it
interesting he been intense and and like
I you know it looked completely like
kind of like weaving a tapestry magic
talent into some sort of something
around at her just pulling energy out of
the air and doing it I liked or
intensity and it was in her movement it
was in her eyes so i think i will give
the most credit to the to the
performance the character in terms of
use was fine and functional for me i
think most of what worked worked because
she played it well i'm actually gonna
mirror pretty much all that and so cool
yep walnut of a period i said we agree i
was up all right if I like she just she
had multiple functions in different
scenes like she was just there to show
them their dark fears and have them turn
on each other and then she was there to
be badass roof telekinetic street
fighter and then she was there to have
that breakdown so macht I could
her out of it know how to turn the Titan
deliver probably the funniest little one
I have a crazy thought which is why did
we need them okay so this I think gets
into Ultron's motivation like we said
that we motivations and thoughts like we
said we have to get into because he gets
so upset when they turn on him you know
just because he wants to destroy the
human race doesn't mean he doesn't want
someone to agree with him he is Tony
Stark's in Tony wants to be loved he
wants to be appreciated and he wants to
be writin yes so that's a character
reason why he wants them around but
ristori story structure wise are they
actually necessary no there are two
macro reasons but not really any micro
reasons like four in story yeah macro
reasons is first one is Joss wanted to
play with new power sets and he wanted
to introduce characters from the comics
that he grew up reading yeah the other
macro thing is actors contracts are
coming up the end of this movie was set
up there like okay it's going to be the
next generation of adventure can you go
wind ultra yeah let's just start you
know one of the things that fascinates
me about him as characters is like you
said it's not the cold equation you know
humans must die yeah you know this is
this is this is an angry intelligence
you know the fact that he can be calm
and quippy and then all sudden he loses
temporal chopped off a guy's arm it's an
immediate childlike response in in as
much as he is has total awareness of
humanity he has no experience right and
what's interesting his vision agrees
with Ultron that humanity is doomed you
know the differences vision doesn't want
to bring up out the doom of the humanity
is like yeah I'll stick around until it
happens you know it's fun to be with
which of which was actually a moment i
really liked because it there was a nice
melancholy to that moment yeah so my
favorite moment with Ultron came in the
very beginning where we see his Genesis
and we see him in the broken robot in
that moment I love the
character how do wish we'd taken longer
to get to get to a proper body for him
and and then my problem was those like I
really there's a lot i like about this I
like a lake house scattered his thoughts
are I like that he's not fully
understanding what's going on I love it
when he killed Jarvis and then the next
time we see him he's got a body and he's
the refined James Spader I feel like the
moment that we got with the roided-out
Ultron it should have been the first
time that we saw him in a fully
functional proper body at all it would
have raised the stakes even higher yeah
you know it's it felt like the movie hit
its emotional height I'm gonna say
probably mid way through act 2 and it
just stayed there once they left the
safe as it was just that that's where it
was going to be in terms of like tone
and pacing and some of your complaints
yes I felt like there were quiet moments
quiet scenes of one-on-one that were
really well written yeah um and then
there were rip your eyes out action
sequences and there wasn't a whole lot
of in between well I mean there was what
four major action sequences we do you
think you know you have the so you have
the initial battle on the Hydra base
then you go to Africa and you destroy
that city then you go to Sol Sol the
story that's in heat and then back to
sanity go back to savoca and you really
destroy him at City each of those
sequences had to be at least 15 to 20
minutes in length that's a hundred
minutes of action in you know a
two-and-a-half-hour movie you know
that's a lot a question for the group
the use of humor I think Joss Whedon
just generally is very good at injected
humour without killing the pacing
because if I'm to make a comparison
there were moments in the climactic
battle fight of Thor the dark world
where they they literally stopped the
scene to make a joke and even though it
was some of the best jokes I wish they
weren't there because they killed the
momentum mm-hmm and I didn't feel
momentum death when the Hulk jumps into
the into the jet and you just your
Ultron off
oh for God's sake anything this gets
thrown down at the plane it's like I
felt like there are a couple points
where during the action sequences when
the use of humor to kind of create
levity either fell flat or felt
strangely inappropriate when cap and for
saved the two cars or the people on the
cars from falling off the bridge and
when they come back and cap is like what
were you napping or something like that
l didn't get out of the scene I actually
thought during the Hulkbuster seen every
time Robert Downey jr. of meta tried to
make a joke didn't work on me when he
was akin the back banner dick move I was
like shut up I but there was what
there's one that worked come on women
Hulk spit out the tenth inning is it I'm
sorry I can't one of the things I think
Josh Wheaton does really really well is
make you care about these characters and
give us these moments where we can
connect with them first one is the
hammer sequence which I loved it's fun
there's also some steaks here right
which is that and it plays out later but
somebody might be able to pick up this
hammer and and the fact that it moves a
little and cap touches it doors but you
see the color and when cap gives up Thor
was just like ahh I'm like I like these
guys I like seeing them just sort of
being together wait am just too foggy
also made it the perfect point for
Ultron to just absolutely just come in
and just throw everything out right the
other one is the love affair between
banner Natasha we're I'm surprised how
well that worked and I suspect that
largely came out of just chemistry that
the actors had because to the best of my
knowledge is no precedent for that one
in the comic book so my favorite moment
from the first Avengers film is the
moment where Widow sees what the Hulk
really is when he hooked up yes sir and
she's terrified she's scared and as I
monster yummy and it's and it's such a
good woman because it looks so real
right and I'm afraid for fringe is
running for her life and so when she
goes to approach him later she's still
scared of him right you can see she's
calm
with him but she cares about him the
first time she says that weird phrase
about how sun's going down yeah and I'm
like oh man I really like this something
like I really really and so those work
for me those were the moments of the
film that I really treasured I was fine
with the romantic subplot between them
and the coupling them together I thought
they flirted well together i liked their
banter and again going to the chemistry
and everything like that I'd like the
way it was written when it was just them
exploring a budding relationship when it
got to be them talking about just
quitting and going away it broke free it
did it didn't break for me but I kind of
wish they hadn't taken it to that step I
was right there in a certain way of the
V animated Justice League where they
there was a lot of flirting on a lot of
implication of Wonder Woman and Batman
but they never actually definitively
paired them off romantically and I kind
of wish it had been kept at that level
that there's obviously something there
but if they ever pursue it we don't need
to spend time in the movie dealing with
it I thought the chemistry um was forced
and it felt like the reason that that
was there is when he went not some store
the African city when he did that I said
to myself okay end of this film he's
going to disappear because he's afraid
of what he can be um and it seemed to me
like okay well to have that have more
emotional impact let's make the steaks
personal I can kind of see what you say
but I'm going to disagree slightly move
and what I think the intent might have
been was to give somebody a personal
reason to go after him not so much that
the loss of him would be more personal
but that it becomes more than just well
suppose we ought around him up now but
that somebody actually cares about
finding him and I think the hoke story
is a sad story you know I don't think
that he does get to have um you know
these servers long-standing
relationships I think he is a character
that is plagued by this dual nature and
I think that him running away I was like
when he when he turned off the camera
right he's in the plane by himself oh my
god this is the end of the TV show right
now this is
him walk another alone McKenzie is sad
music this is this is this is who he is
like his life is sad superficial things
um I loved caps costume finally Oh
they've got before and this was the best
yep I really did um superficial thing I
didn't like Ultron's mouth movements
something about it didn't yeah to fluid
yeah yeah it seemed like Hawkeye ever
his quiver ever even lose any no no I
hated the fact that the Ultron robots
were so easily dispatched and the and
this happens and I know what happens but
once again it felt like we were fighting
there's just hoard of faceless enemies
and all you have to do is kind of punch
over poco more knock him over woods it's
the inverse ninja law one ninja on his
own is indestructible 40 ninjas easily
dispatched by the out right there were a
few moments by the way where I really
appreciated that they slow the action
down for us yeah like when they were
around the drill and it was the spinning
shot like it's very slow it was just one
of those things it's like thank you like
there's just so many hundreds of action
movies you could point to where the
actions so fast it's exciting and but
you can't see a damn thing yeah I just
gonna say the Deus Ex um airship my life
that they brought the the kid who was
controlling those was the kid from the
winter soldier okay I found myself on
two minds of that because when it first
showed up I'm like that's a little
cheesy but I then kind of became a
sucker for the fact that it was the
original Helicarrier and not one of the
new ones that they came up with and
because it fed into what I talked about
before which is that they're that it's
there so that they can save everybody
and it because it fed into something
that I like that was an aspect that I
like you so much I was willing to be
forgiven yeah the mid-credits scene
alright we get Josh Brolin we get our
Thanos it was just there yeah you had to
have it so we know it'll be war
gonna be about okay this just felt like
a reminder yeah and I've had this
argument with you before because you
were annoyed at the Howard the Duck joke
at the end of guardians of the galaxy
but I will make the argument that there
have only ever been to post or
mid-credits teams that have mattered one
was at the end of Iron Man where where
we see Nick Fury he says the Avengers
initiative and the other was made
credits on the first Avengers where we
see Thanos because we didn't know that
he was coming other than that none of
them have mattered other previews are
for shadowing well we had claw which
obviously will feed into Black Panther
everything about for Vision Quest and
everything that Ivan often is it right I
wanna play off in right now well then
they name-dropped hell yeah which is I
mean obviously hell is you know heaven
help but not hell which even with one L
is a realm that Thor has had to deal
with my ex there is a fair amount of
play of the divide between captain
america and tony start and that's me and
kind of surprised me because I was like
they seem way too comfortable with each
other in this final scene I kind of took
it as the adrenaline had worn off yet
that moment where cap walks in with
Widow to see Lydia Avengers be group d
point on the right I was like now it
feels like caps in charge and they're
getting Tony out of the way um so um
overall I really like this movie did you
that's a visage of everyone who's been
paying attention I know I mean I enjoyed
it I had a lot of problems with it um
and but i'm glad i saw i really want
spider-man to be in an Avengers film and
for the life of me I could not find room
for him and I am really worried about
trying them trying to shoehorn him in
that I suppose to the point that I was
gonna make which was at no point during
this film was did I think spider-man
belong in here and if spider-man shows
up in the Avengers infinity wars
movies cool I want to see him but I
don't want him on the Avengers I like
the movie I enjoyed it it had problems I
can see those the problems bothered me
less than they bothered you I mean
overall they said I can see Weeden um
much more in this film than I could in
the first Avengers and I think that's a
good thing his writing was more
prevalent um you know his directorial
choice is more more clear having seen
this I would now love to see Whedon do a
Christopher Nolan where no second unit
let me see him do his movie and his
movie alone because if if he can Manish
but this much of a state of his stamp on
a movie that is part of the Marvel
Universe give the man two hundred
million dollars and low he'll be able to
do that for a Marvel Studios production
he'll have to go somewhere else yeah but
I agree i think from scene to scene was
clunky at times but aside from that I
just I just had a lot of fun so thank
you very much for joining us what were
your thoughts on this thing you grew the
folks you like dim or do you agree with
certain insane people who had more
issues whatever you felt or drop
somebody go in the comments and let's
talk about it until next time this
council is a jerk